cruise down the street and you leave
chaos in your wake as you drive around
your bike you've probably noticed the
wind whipping around you here's what the
airflow looks like these disturbances in
the air and other fluids are known as
turbulence want to find these fragmented
flows is one of the greatest problems in
math if researchers can find a way to
capture this chaos in an equation we'll
be better able to understand this
universal event from locomotion to ocean
currents to how gases move throughout
galaxies turbulence is everywhere if we
look close enough blow out a candle and
watch the swirling of the smoke trails
disrupt a stream with a stake and see
the little whirlpools form in the wake
on larger scales ocean currents sweep
across the globe storms turn the
atmosphere on earth and other planets
how can researchers study the chaotic
phenomenon known as turbulence and
what's preventing them from capturing
the full picture fluids or gases and
liquids that flow and adapt to the shape
of a container think water honey blood
in air they have quantifiable properties
like viscosity velocity pressure and
density that mathematicians can track
over time they're also governed by the
laws of conservation of mass energy and
momentum mathematicians describe fluid
flows using the navier-stokes equations
you can think of these equations as
Newton's second law for the motion of
fluids force equals mass times
acceleration on the left side of the
equation is the density and acceleration
or the change in velocity of a particle
of fluid over time on the right side is
change in pressure
internal forces of stress and finally
external forces acting on the fluid
smooth continuous fluid flows like in a
gentle streamer pipe are called laminar
flows the equations work well for
describing how particles behave in
laminar
but most fluids in nature are not so
orderly they can be really chaotic or
turbulent in the case of your afternoon
drive the air starts as a laminar flow
as it meets the front of your car what
happens next depends on your car's shape
speed texture temperature as well as the
properties of the air and atmosphere
most cars have an aerodynamic shape
which minimizes the turbulence initially
and the air moves over the car the
molecules closest to your doors stay put
and interact with its surface further
away air molecules travel at different
speeds these layers of different air
create friction and turbulence what
you'd feel as drag the result is war
disease and Eddie's that in turn
generate more and more swirls ever heard
of the butterfly effect it says a flap
of a butterfly's wing in Japan could set
up the chain of events that could
trigger a tornado in Texas a week later
these Eddie's that we get more Eddie's
and vortices and so on become too
complicated for mathematicians to
predict or quantify where will Eddie's
form how many will there be
where will energy be concentrated or
dispersed plug in certain values in the
equations may spit out infinite values
for velocity this breaks down or blows
up the model because of these challenges
and the possibilities that understanding
turbulence could lead to there's a
million-dollar reward for proving honor
that the navier-stokes equations always
work or that they sometimes fail meaning
velocity becomes infinite until then who
knows what chain of events you'll start
by taking your Sunday Drive
[Music]
you